trade negotiations with China are on the
horizon the European Parliament's
committee on international trade has
given its green light to launching
negotiation with China on investment and
market access the deal would replace the
26 bilateral agreements that EU member
states currently have with China members
of the European Parliament want
transparent negotiations and are laying
down their conditions a balanced
agreement must include the social and
labor standards must include
ecologically criteria for the
development of the beneficial
development of the enterprises in both
markets in China as well as in the
European Union easing cross-border trade
when a buyer and a seller are making a
transaction from different countries
which law should they implement in the
case of a dispute to avoid such a legal
headache sales and purchases could all
come under a set of uniform eu-wide
rules on condition however that both
parties agree to it via Hoffman dahsyat
stretch design for her adviser Deseret
subash terminus and n paws on zol zein
fania under name and shayan online
version of cleanser wash and super
homeless problem is fri a moment destash
online [ __ ] off that consumers
heightened when system by sherman
chakkar laga Xena's NZ leave her home
univ deutschland leave her home una
franchise non-abelian on a lien on
Lena's and Oscar schloss anant a salon
sukham finish mezzo zion